hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that a lot of you have been
requesting for quite some time now for
the past few days the Internet's been
flooded with information about young
tanto la that woman from Nigeria as and
here's a great victory in the 52nd
annual New York State scholastic
championship
I was the championship was held in
Saratoga Springs in New York from March
9th to March 10th and I was trying to
acquire a game that's why I didn't show
it up until now and I acquired it from
u.s. chess to be more exact new dot US
chess dot org I will put a link to it in
the description below there will be an
entire article if we want to read a bit
more about well about young taani and
about this entire championship so like I
mentioned the his entire family moved
from Nigeria in 2017 they've been living
in a homeless shelter
up until now and well it's just an
amazing story that well that in all
likelihood would not happen if if the
young gentleman here did not play chess
and if you are wondering about the
blurry photo of mr. Milo Kong we do not
have a photo of mr. Milo Kong he's also
I believe below eight years old rated
almost 1,400 and I thought you know it'd
be maybe not use mr. hoodie guy for such
a young person so instead we are using
mr. Hudak kid and for this reason I will
be not wearing a who did this video
since you know I only were the hoodie
when I honored the hoodie guy but yeah I
would out further ado let's check out
this very nice game
Michael conch op opens with E 4 and we
have B 6 Owens defense by by young Tony
I will vie for Bishop to b7 attacking
the center with the pieces right from
the start and now you do have to defend
it you can either defend it with Knight
to c3 this is a popular option but also
Bishop to d3 and here Knight to f6 for
those of you who are interested I would
just like to point out that there is
there's a famous miniature by jockey no
greco who played it with the white
pieces and it's one of the games that
really got me hooked conscious when I
was younger
I'll just show it as it's only
seven moves here a Greco's opponent
played f7 sorry f5 greco captured he
allowed this Bishop captures on g2 move
here we have Queen to h5 check better
sorry g6 blocking check
we have pawn captures and here Greco's
opponent just attacked the Queen with
the knight Knight to f6 and the Greco
here in great style just captured the
pawn on a seven delivering check and
that the King has nowhere to go you have
to capture the Queen Knight captures and
here
Bishop to g6 is checkmate when I first
saw this game I was just blown away and
well it's one of the reasons I came to
really really enjoy chess you know to to
the to the amount ah I enjoy it today
definitely one of the greater reasons
but getting back to this game here
taani did not go for f5 rather he went
for Knight to f6 now with a double
attack against the e4 pawn this is
basically the idea of this opening and
also you are preparing d5 we have f3 now
defending this pawn and we have e 6 now
preparing to develop the dark square
bishop we have c4 by white and here d5
and it's interesting this is not
although this is not played very often
it often in top-tier tournaments but in
one such instance for example in 2015
Pharaoh save had this position with the
white pieces against mama dr.aman BDR
plays d5 here it was a really exciting
game it was played in in the Vladimir
Petro immoral and here feather serve
immediately captured see capture son d5
but in this game we have first be 5 so
Milo Kong plays a move that was not
played before and now from move six we
have a new game D captures uncie for was
played here and what do you do now it's
interesting the point of this is if you
move the knight then was just gonna
capture on d5 and regain a better
position but here after D characters in
c4 tani
immediately sees this initiative because
now it's not very good for black to go
he captures and f6 then C captures on d3
captures captures and now white will
have an impossible time trying to hold
on to this d4 pawn
well let's say 92 bugs just gonna keep
on attacking it and after you develop
with the castles then we
that castle's comes with a triple attack
against the pawn and now there's no
point in defending it anymore Bishop to
e3 runs into 85 and now it's just over
you can put d5 but night before attacks
the Queen and there's now a triple
attack against this pawn so now you will
lose the pawn in black ruins a winning
position so here you can go for captures
you have to go Bishop captures in c4 and
here Tania just goes Knight to d5 an
excellent squirt for the square for the
knight on d5 of course if white
recaptures that captures a ton d5 then
black will be the one having the bishop
repair and it's a nice open position so
it will be better for black but okay
Knight to c3 and now Bishop to b4
developing and attacking tani doesn't
attack the pink piece but rather pins
the attacked piece so Bishop to b4 and
now Bishop to d2 Bishop to d2 is the
first well bigger mistake of the game
you do have to play in 92 you have to
protect the knight on c3 but also you
have to cover the pawn on d4 here Bishop
to d2 is played and now of course you
see how black seizes advantage here
white already played f3 the pawn on d4
is unguarded so white must now pay the
price Queen to h4 check connecting with
the King and the d4 pawn the price of
this well foul play is one D pawn so g3
preventing check Queen Catherine d4 and
now comes Knight captures on d5 and here
you could go for Bishop captures on b2
itani finds a different plan that also
sets a trap for white with Queen
captures on e5 with check and here you
have to go King to f2 it's or you could
block with Knight to e2 but here his
opponent falls a false for a trap we
have Knight back to e3 but now of course
you realize that the night is not really
guarded by the bishop because the bishop
is pin so here you see the move Queen
captures on e3 with check the bishop of
course cannot capture now Bishop to e2
is played blocking trick and now comes
just Queen captures on D to being up
material tani just now exchanges
everything and goes into into a better
endgame Queen captures with Bishop
CalPERS and e2 with check King capture
son d2 and now comes
probably my favorite move of the game
here you could castle and okay you'll
develop them it we see five of the night
bring both Brooks into the game but
that's the thing there's no need to
castle and Youngstown he knows this the
the winter of the board east seven is a
nice dark square white only has light
square Bishop the king is much more
useful in the center so here King t7 is
what tani played without castling he's
just preparing to bring the rook into
the game and this is just a a wonderful
idea
rook to see one by white also developing
going after the c7 pawn and here while
he could defend it with c5 most likely
black did not want to give white a
target so first rook the d8 check King
to e3 and not rook to d7 just defending
the c7 pawn Knight to h3 White has to
figure out a way a way how to get this
Knight into the game
we have h6 and now g4 and here black
just pushes g5 takes away even the f4
Square from White's Knight rook H the d1
and now just rook captures on d1 Bishop
captures to white wants to still keep an
eye on this pawn here and only now the
stand go for c5 we have nice - f2 Knight
to c6 now finally developing tonight and
preparing to bring the rook into the
game night the d3 and now comes Knight
to d4 and excellent score outpost for
the night also pressuring the pawn on f3
we have before by white and now comes
rook to d8 pawn captures on c5 and now
not recapturing and allowing Knight
captures but rather b5 closing up at the
C file oh yes giving white a pass C pawn
but the bishop and night key you know
keep an eye on the c6 square so there's
no danger of white pushing it for the
moment if you go night before then
a5 can be played and so on so here
Knights the e5 is played preparing to
push c6 but tiny jumps right into it we
have Brooke to d5 attacking the knight
and here white plays an interesting move
c6 offering the night with check but in
return the white also captures the
knight on d4 so this is what what tani
went for we're broke captures an e5 with
check King captures on d4 now attacking
the rook but just roof to d5 with
King now has to move with King back to
e3 and now Bishop to c8 getting out of
the way and Bishop to e2 pressuring the
b5 pawn and here taani just plays King
to d6 and as this is the only game
available from this championship that
Stanny played it just says on the
website a new dot a US chest that
eventually black born the game
I don't think white actually resigned in
this position because it is a bit too
early but as you can see black is up
upon and well it will be a fairly assume
that the white will also lose the c6
pawn so black will be up to pawns and
will have a winning endgame one such
idea might be lets say h4 trying to
create some weaknesses here and maybe
free up the h-file for whites rook
but then after rook to c5 there's just
no way of defending that c6 pawn I would
say Ruby want check King c7 and now
after captures captures a black will
capture this pawn and well eventually
white will be able to produce some
problems for black but nothing black
will not be able to take care of sir now
after this King to d6 move this is the
the only position we have available to
us but the taani were successfully won
this game and he did not only win this
game out of the six games he played he
won the well the event in his division
with five and a half out of six so quite
quite an impressive result and it's
interesting that because well it's
really just became a wonderful story
like I said the entire internet was was
flooded with it there was also a
fundraiser happening and as you can see
the goal of the fund was to reach fifty
fifty thousand dollars to help him
young young tani and his family but in
just three days they they were able to
gather over one hundred and seventy
thousand dollars so that's very
impressive you can see how you know
whenever you know one person can't do
anything but whenever one joins up you
can see over 3,000 people joined in this
fundraiser and I believe it's still
going on there you can see words of
appreciation from his family it's just
it's just a wonderful wonderful story
that would never have happened if if
tani did not play chess so that's that's
what I really enjoy about chess if you
play it I mean only good things can come
from it if you don't play then maybe you
will just miss out on an amazing
opportunity as they dimension in the
article Tanya and his family moved to
New York in 2017 from Nigeria they were
they were afraid to stay there and you
know living in a homeless shelter ever
since and this I mean it's amazing that
an eight-year-old can win a New York
championship in his division and well
that Dean you know people from from the
entire world can just you know work
together and and offer them some
opportunity in life it's I mean it's
just amazing so that that's why I really
wanted to show this game and you know
give this story to even though if you're
if you're following any chess chess news
online I'm sure you've already heard of
it but yeah now if I can have out of six
and extremely impressive result
especially since it was eight seed in
the tournament so he was I believe 200
rating points lower rated than the top
seed which makes his victory all the
more all the more impressive but iam
like I said the first thing you will see
in the description below will be a link
to the to the new dot US chess dot org
articles so do check it out there's a
lot more information there and yeah as
you can see I would like to you know
wish a happy birthday to even you'll be
Church who is maybe even watching this
video now if you do you know it means
you've gotten home safely so I'm very
glad to hear that and also we have
another birthday wish for this video
from Maria to Martin as you can see she
she made this edit those are belated
birthday wishes there you can see hello
everyone and welcome to the long-awaited
minkowski saga before we start the match
I just wanted to wish Martin a belated
Happy Birthday she did the edit the
graphics are her hers and you know she
did a very nice job Martin I also wish
you a happy birthday you're a very lucky
fellow you know your birthday your
girlfriend wishing you a happy birthday
on a chess channel that you
enjoy very often as she saw States swim
that's basically it I do hope you
enjoyed the game and that you've enjoyed
this story I'm still just extremely
impressed I mean it's just it's it's
really really good to play chess because
beautiful things can happen as such as
as you've witnessed here so yeah I I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank and Rima cuca luetgert
a recipe pricing Bobby treat Paul
staples for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content checking up on
your suggestions such as this one a
lovely story continuing in the
capablanca saga and you know picking up
whatever goes on in the world I think
you'll I'll see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day